لم تعد مباريات كره القدم حكرا على الذكور
فمونديال قطر 2022 يشهد حضور النسائيا
كبيرا في مدرجات ملاعبه فقد رصد ارتفاعا
بنسبه 65% للجنس اللطيف من الفتيات
اللواتي اصبحنا يتابعنا المنتخبات
ولاعبيها فمنهم من تشارك في الهدى ومنهم
ان ترتدي الوان فريق بلدها او المنتخب
المفضل لديها
كاس عالم اخضر
وهو كاس مميز لانه يقام في بلد رائع
ومختلف
دائما في المونديال وكثير من النساء في
الارجنتين يقومن بذلك وهذا امر طبيعيا
بالنسبه لنساء بلدي
صغير وكره القدم تشعرنا بالسعاده ولوكا
مودريتش
ده اكثر من اي شيء
منتخبات المغرب والارجنتين والبرازيل لها
حصه الاسد من المشجعه فلن تتردد مشجعه تلك
المنتخبات بالظهور وهن يرتدين قمصان
منتخباتهم وسط الدوحه في سوق واقف ومنطقه
الشارب واللؤلؤه والكورنيش وحتى في محيط
الملاعب التي تقام على اراضيها المباريات
الختاميه للحصول على كاس عالم كره القدم
هذا العام الذي وحد العرب والعربيات حول
اللعبه الاكثر شعبيه في العالم
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر